appreciate it good afternoon everyone
thank you for coming bonjour
my name is steve bell and i'm the
interim chief of the ottawa police
service i want to thank our partners
from the ontario provincial police and
the royal canadian mounted police for
being here today with me i have deputy
commissioner chris harkins of the opp
and deputy commissioner mike duham of
the rcmp
the auto police service the rcmp and the
opp as well as numerous police agencies
in ontario and quebec are now here in
ottawa we've been bolstering our
resources developing clear plans and
preparing to take action
the action is in imminent
in the past few days we've been
communicating directly with the unlawful
protesters we've told them they must
leave and we have warned them the
consequences of disobeying these rules
we want to end this unlawful protest
peacefully and safely
we want to prepare we are prepared to
employ lawful techniques to remove the
unlawful protesters from our streets
today i want to speak directly to our
residents
and our community specifically the
residents and businesses of our downtown
core
your safety everyone's safety is our
priority we know that you've been
through a lot and i know that ongoing
unlawful process have caused pain and
suffering to you and your loved ones
we're committed to returning to your
streets back to you and back to normal
we know that increased police presence
within the area may be distressing
our officers are here to help you and
your community they care about the
community and they're here to help keep
you safe while we complete this
operation
overnight and into today we've begun to
harden the perimeter around the protests
we're installing fencing and other
barriers throughout the area
in furtherance of our efforts to bring
our city back to a state of normalcy
we've introduced a secured area the
secured area includes the area from
bronson avenue to the canal and from the
queensway to parliament hill
the secured area includes almost 100
checkpoints that will have police
presence to ensure that those seeking
entry to that secure area for a unlawful
reason such as joining a proto protest
cannot enter the downtown core
again i know that these are measures
that our community is not used to
they will be in place only as long as
necessary to un remove the unlawful
protests
our officers are aware of the impact on
you and we're taking every step we can
to minimize the impact on our residents
and businesses while keeping out those
who could do more harm to our community
we want to reassure everyone that if you
live work or have a lawful reason to be
in the area there will be minimal
impacts on your access
once through the checkpoints those with
a lawful reason will be free to move
about individuals may leave the secure
area at any time
as we continue to increase our actions
we will be communicating them directly
to the public we have open lines of
communication with our schools and other
institutions in the area
to those engaged in the unlawful protest
if you want to leave under your own
terms now is the time to do it
i'm available to take questions thank
you
and i'll invite each media to come to
the microphone
and ask a question please when you
search the question start with your name
and the media you represent
is
hello chief natalie van roy from ctv
ottawa are ottawa police asking
businesses
near the red zone to stay closed for an
extended period of time
so as i indicated so thank you first
thank you very much for the question
as i indicated we've developed this
secure area where people who live work
or have lawful reasons to be there are
free to come and go we're just
restricting the area from people who
have come in over the past number of
weeks particularly on the weekends as
we're getting towards to be engaged in
unlawful activity we have several
officers in the area both on foot and in
vehicles to ensure the safety and
security of the neighborhoods and the
areas that surround
where the prosta protest footprint is
what measures are being considered if
protesters do not comply if they do not
leave that secure area
so we've been really clear with everyone
since the very beginning this is it's
time to go your time in our city has
come to an end and you must leave we've
engaged in interactions with the
protesters to to attempt to
persuade negotiate with them to leave
the footprint of our area we will
continue to do that but what i can tell
you is we have a deliberate plan of
action to take in order to make sure
that our streets are turned back to our
residents and our community is turned
back to normal
hi elizabeth laplante i'm from tva news
in montreal when are you planning to
intervene
for the kids
in the protest
so thanks for the question one of the
key concerns that we've had as we've
planned and and looked at how we want to
proceed to end this protest is the
number of children that remain in there
we continue to work with our partners
from the children's aid society and
other social services to look at the
best most safest way to have children
removed from the area
prior to any sort of police action we've
had members of our police service
continue to engage with the protesters
to identify that it is not a good place
for children to be that they should make
every attempt to remove children from
the area all of our planning has been
very considerate of the people that are
within the demonstration zone including
the children will they be the first to
be removed as i indicated we've worked
really hard to make sure all of our
plans are very deliberate around
protecting children that may be in that
footprint
mr bell mackenzie gray with cdb national
news to be frank it's been 21 days now
and the residents of this city have been
pretty clear that the police in the city
have completely bungled dealing with
this protest it's not the first time
we've had a press conference here from
the police saying there's a new plan to
deal with it so why should any of the
residents of the city believe that this
time is going to be different
so thank you for the question um
i think you just need to go outside and
look at the presence we have right now
we're taking unprecedented steps through
support of both federal provincial
legislation
municipal increase in in fines for
bylaws as well as injunctions to bring
all that together to work with our
partners from the opp and rcmp to amass
a plan and amass the resources we need
to actually execute that plan as you're
seeing in the occurrence that's happened
the activity that's happened with police
over the last day and a half or so
you're seeing a much increased presence
of officers that is to indicate that we
are at the end of this protest we will
take what action we need to deliberately
safely lawfully end these demonstrations
i'm happy you mentioned going outside
because if you walked on wellington
street right now there are two guys in a
hot tub and there's a bouncy castle
across from them can you assure the
residents of the city that this will no
longer happen and that the parties that
have happened on wellington street for
the last three weekends will end this
week
that's what we're here to say today we
absolutely are committed to end this
unlawful demonstration we have the plan
we have the commitment we have the
resources and we have the amazing
partnership of all policing partners to
make sure that this unlawful
demonstration comes to an end
chief bell thanks for taking our
questions um you're talking about
setting up checkpoints making sure
people have a lawful reason to be going
downtown how are these going to work um
been seeing some reports that people are
just asking oh why are you going down
okay go ahead so what's going to be
stopping protesters from just lying and
saying they work downtown or they live
downtown
so as we indicated we have um over a
hundred checkpoints in this secure area
that we've established officers are
continuing to be informed um of uh the
the lawful reasons why how they can stop
and challenge people and then looking to
ensure that people are entering the area
who live there who work there or who
have a lawful reason such as a medical
appointment to attend there our officers
have that information and are
intervening on people who are not
supposed to be there stopping them and
allowing people that should be there
their lawful right to move around in
those areas
yeah and just on the difficulty of
dealing with children in the protest
we my colleagues have been speaking to
some people out there right now who have
kids are saying it's a completely safe
place they don't plan on leaving anytime
soon and encouraging other families to
bring their kids out there
just how did the police navigate the
situation with child with a children's
aid if people aren't going to be leaving
the police plan on coming in and
separating families
so as as i indicated earlier we continue
to work with the children's aid society
and our planners to make sure that the
safety of any
children or youth that are in that area
in the footprint of the demonstration is
utmost in our priority as we look to
dismantle this demonstration
chief bell john willing with the citizen
do you have a goal in terms of how many
trucks you want to remove from the core
daily or even by the end of this long
weekend
so we won't be establishing any goals or
targets what i can tell you is we we are
continuing to to dialogue discuss with
protesters in there uh identifying that
it is time for them to go that this is
coming to an end and that we will
continue to increase our actions until
ultimately everyone is gone from that
area that area is returned to the
citizens of ottawa and we have normalcy
in the downtown core thank you have you
secured heavy tow availability for the
next few days we we continue to work uh
on our plans we've developed all those
plans and we aren't seeing any issues
with the ability to remove vehicles at
this point
um has you felt it's a joint canelo from
cbc news a little bit on that same theme
he said earlier it's going to be
methodical it's going to take time
can you give us a sense about of how
much time you think it will take and you
know we're on to a weekend number four
are you expecting
more people in the demonstrator
reinforcements as you say to come back
like what do you see happening over the
next little while so thank you for the
question um what i can tell you is the
steps the deliberate steps we've taken
to create the secure zone under the
powers that have been granted to us
under the federal emergencies act are
directly aligned to make sure that we
don't see the numbers in the
demonstration bolstered over the weekend
we have an a very deliberate plan that
will be methodical and will take time
for us to progress through to be able to
completely remove anyone from the core
so what i can tell you is this weekend
will look very different than the past
three weekends and for people who like
have kids who are coming to school here
you know there's a high school nearby
there's a public school maybe offices
are you asking people not to come
tomorrow what you know there's concerns
about from parents as you can imagine
so i can absolutely i can absolutely
understand that there's concerns from
all pockets of our community about
what's going on
we continue to work with institutions
like the school boards to identify any
sort of concerns that may exist within
the footprint and we'll continue to
provide public safety or media through
media advisories to all of our community
to let them know what's happening how we
progress and if we have any immediate or
emerging safety concerns that people
need to know about
hi chief laura osmond the canadian press
i'm just wondering how critical the
emergencies act powers that have been
granted to you by the federal government
are in terms of your plan is this
something you would have been able to do
without that legislation invoked
so thanks it's a great question
what i can tell you is we've seen a
growing frustration within our community
within the provincial government within
the federal government around the
activities that are occurring here
we've also seen the growth in our
authorities and ability to actually
successfully deal with the demonstration
unprecedented that unlawful
demonstration like we're seeing downtown
in our core
all of those legislation pieces of
legislation and supports we've got from
different levels of government have
directly and actively contributed to our
ability to ultimately say we are in a
position to move forward and look to end
this demonstration
of course downtown is not the only place
that these trucks have been amassing
there are encampments all over the city
more were popping up last weekend you
had to shut down
what assurances can you give people that
as you direct people away from the
downtown core over the long weekend as
people are trying to flood into ottawa
that it's not going to end up in their
communities
so
i would understand the concern about
that absolutely what i can tell you is
we've had great partnership through the
opp the rcmp other municipal police
agencies to make sure that we have
amassed the number of members officers
support functions in and around the
ottawa area to be able to make sure that
we not only demobilize the demonstration
that exists but that we look at
protecting ourselves against just
displacing it our goal is to take our
streets back our goal is to actually
give the streets of ottawa back to the
community that own it and deserve it we
will continue to do that while trying to
ensure ensuring that this doesn't
actually just displace to somewhere else
hi chief bell
frederick
so
you mentioned just earlier before that
you're still negotiating or speaking
with people that own the heavy vehicles
over there
so are you still at that point where
you're trying to get them to leave on
their own or you're past that point and
you know that you're gonna have to
intervene with force
so we'll never be past that point
i implore anyone that's there get in
your truck we will
navigate safe passage for you to leave
our city streets we want this to end
this demonstration to end peacefully we
want people to realize that it is coming
to an end and not
not require us to escalate in terms of
how we look to deal with demobilizing it
we will never stop trying to get people
to leave our streets that's exactly what
we want them to do just know that
there's a deliberate plan there's
commitment and there's the resourcing
that we now have in place to actually
finally end this but it can be ended by
all the demonstrators that sit there by
getting in their vehicles and going home
are you negotiating or in talks at all
with people that are
or say that they are at the head of this
convoy organizers per se are you
negotiating with them at all so as i
indicated we continue to negotiate with
individuals and with people that
represent different pockets within the
demonstration group it is our desire it
is in everyone's best interest it is
absolutely what we want to do is to have
this end peacefully we want people to go
home we will talk to anyone who we need
to talk to for them to go home but the
demonstrators there need to know we have
commitment we have a plan this needs to
end and you don't think that there's
going to be a fourth weekend of big
parties and celebration like just like
we've seen last weekend i can't place
any timelines on when it will ultimately
culminate i can tell you it will be a
very different picture in the downtown
core this weekend than it has been from
the previous three weekends
sir charles gagnon with the door
newspaper uh
again talking this morning with truckers
inside their truck they're not coming
out they're not leaving
so
how will you enforce whatever you
need to enforce are you going to take
them out of their trucks it's not going
to happen
so i'm not in a position to be able to
give up any of the operational issues
that we've discussed what i can tell you
is we've taken into consideration many
different circumstances that could exist
within the footprint of the
demonstration and in and around it and
we're actually planning for several
different eventualities i'll say it
again we want people to peacefully leave
but i can tell you that if they do not
peacefully leave we have plans
strategies and tactics to be able to get
them to leave and obviously i don't know
when you guys are going to go in or
whatever but there's still lots of
people just walking on wellington street
and all that that are supporting so
what and they're probably going to
continue what are you saying to these
people if they don't want to leave
either so our message has been pretty
consistent around that and more
importantly the message from our
community and our residents has been
pretty consistent around that do not
come to our downtown core we are tired
of what's occurring there we're sick of
what's happening in our streets so leave
our area we will continue with that
message this weekend but you're seeing
an increased enforcement presence and we
won't be allowing people to come down
for the unlawful activity of engaging in
demonstrations thank you
thank you everyone this concludes our
meet availability